hey this is Henry and welcome to today's
tutorial what we're gonna be doing today
is building a simple to-do list with the
parent stack and in case you don't know
what the Pern stack stands for it is P
for post grass be for express R for
react GS as our friend and framework and
an N for no GS as our backing language
now by the end of this video you'll have
a better understanding of how all these
different types of technologies interact
with each other and go on to building
more complicated applications now let me
give you guys a quick demo so let's say
I need to clean my room which I really
need to do so I can add that I can even
edit the information so let's change
this to car yeah I'll just keep it like
that and then I can also delete the
information so even though this is just
a simple credit application and it is
trivial there's a lot of things that's
happening between the front and back end
so in the next section we're going to go
over a diagram or review of how this
application is going to work and give
you guys the big picture now before I
move on there is going to be some
prerequisites or more like pre setup
like the first thing you already need is
to have no GS installed second you also
need to have Postgres installed and if
you don't I'm just gonna give you guys a
video that's why I'm gonna look at at
the bottom of my video that's going to
show you guys how to properly install it
besides that you guys need to have a
basic understanding what jobs grab
reaction yes and if you understand
RESTful API so that's going to also help
you guys a lot throughout the whole
process but besides that I'll see you
guys in the next section
okay so let's just quickly go over this
diagram to get the big picture so you
can see that this is going to be our
front end so right here you can see the
submit button along with the data that's
going to be able to get edit and delete
it so anytime I click the submit edit or
delete button within my react
application what I'm really am doing is
sending an HTTP request to my restful
api and depending on the HTTP request
and the route that's being hit it is
going to tell my database or it's going
to instruct my database a Rudd type of
[ __ ] needs to get done okay so anytime
I click the submit button I'm sending a
post request to create a to-do anytime I
want to edit something I'm sending a
pull request to update to do delete
delete and then when I want to read it
to do I'm gonna use a get request so I
think one the hardest part about
learning how full psych application work
is really understanding restful api so
I'm gonna really oversimplify the
definitions but this is really all you
need to know a RESTful API uses Transfer
Protocol in order to run credits so what
I mean by that is that our transfer
protocol is going to be HTTP requests so
we have access to post put delete get a
lot more but these are the four main
ones but essentially we're going to be
using these HTTP requests and then our
restful api is going to take them and
then it's going to instruct the keyword
it is instruct our database of what type
of crowd operation needs to get done
okay so a lot of the misconception that
a lot of people have is that credence
occur within the restful api but that's
not true at all rather the credits only
occur within the database wonder that's
post grass or MongoDB or MySQL it only
occurs within our database so I'm just
going to say this a restful api is just
going to take our HTTP requests and then
it's going to instruct okay so hopefully
that makes a lot more sense and in next
section we're going to start building a
restful api
okay so let's start building our restful
api so the first thing I did was created
a simple Pern to do folder and you can
name this whatever you want but really
the big idea is that it's going to hold
our client and server folder so I'm
gonna first do mcdeere server and then
I'm going to CD into that server so you
can see here it's popping up right there
and immediately I'm going to run NPM in
it so NPM init is going to keep track of
all our packages inside our application
and we're going to answer a few more
questions to give more details so entry
point is what's going to glue our
application together so after that I'm
going to do MPM install Express PG and
course so what are these libraries well
Express allows us to quickly create a
server in nodejs and then we have course
which allows different domain
applications to interact with each other
for example our server is going to be
running on localhost 5000 in our react
application application is going to be
running on localhost 3000 now finally PG
is there to connect our database with
our server in order to run some
post-grad queries okay so once we set
this thing up I'm going to say touch
index at jas which is going to again be
the glue I'm going to go over here or
the libraries so I'm gonna require
Express and then I'm going to create a
variable call up which is going to take
my Express library and then it's going
to run it now at pause all these cool
methods in order to create a server so
anytime we want our server to start we
have to listen to your part number so
app got listen for five thousand is what
we're going to be listening it to and
then I'm gonna have a callback function
that's going to indicate has started so
server has started on port and a test us
out really quick to see if it works I'm
going to say node index and indeed it
does work but the thing this is that I
don't want to use node I highly
recommend that you NPM sell globally
node Mon because every time we want to
see changes we have to restart terminal
and turn it back on so by using no man
or no Mon you're going to watch
single file and then every time there's
a change that's going to be done it's
going to on some instantly restart it
so no Mon hey and you can see it's going
to be watching a file and then the next
thing I want to do is create some
malware so middleware I'm gonna use up I
use so anytime we're gonna create a mill
where you have to use about use and I'm
gonna put pores and I totally forgot to
require that so con scores okay so now
that that's setup that's all we have to
do and I just kind of want to jump ahead
as well that's anytime we're building a
full psych application you need to get
data from the client side and the only
way to get data from the client side is
that we have to get it from the request
that body object so let me show you how
we can do that so by using this oops let
me go back inside here so this right
here essentially is allowing us to give
us access to request that body and then
we can get JSON data okay so this is
still a little bit confusing we're going
to build and I'm going to reference this
a lot okay so see in the next section
and we're going to create a database and
a table for postgrads
all right so let's get started building
our database on table so I'm gonna first
show you guys this diagram to give you
guys a big overview of the commands
we're going to be using so you can see
those are Postgres inside there there's
going to be a lot of other databases
like to do databases or hotel database
now inside these databases we're going
to have a table so in this case I'm
going to create a table or I'm going to
create a database call to do database
and then inside there I'm going to
create a table called to do now their
purpose of having a table is that if
there's anything that's related to room
for example in this database then it's
going to be placed inside the room table
anything that's related to guests is
going to be placed inside the guests
table okay and writing a database for
creating a database is as easy as saying
create database and in specifying the
name along with the semicolon and then
after that we have to move inside that
database and then we have to run create
table to do and we don't stop there we
also have to define a schema and the
reason why a schema is so important is
because we don't want to put anything
inside our database you want to be
specific and what we're going to be
putting inside there and then finally as
you can see here we have all these
different commands that we can run both
in our post-grad terminal in order to
make it easy for us to move around so
let's get started so I'm gonna go back
to my visual studio code and right off
the bat I'm going to create a file
called database dot SQL and the reason I
created this is because it's going to
make it more visually pleasing when we
write our commands so let's create
database so great database and we're
going to name it Aspern to do all right
semicolon and then next we're going to
say create table and then to do now I
have to specify what it's going to look
like so let me just set this little
preference ease up first thing I'm going
to do is to do ID and the reason why I
have to do ID is because I want to make
sure that this to do is going to be
unique so for example anytime I'm trying
to delete or trying to update or get a
specific to do
I just want to reference this to do ID
because it's what's going to make it
distinguishable from the other to do
and then I'm going to say cereal hi
monkey so what is this so primary key is
exactly what I just said last time
essentially indicates that this value
right here or this column is going to
make this entire to do unique from the
other two dues and then we have cereal
which is going to be this function
that's going to increase our primary key
to ensure uniqueness so if you're still
a little bit confused don't worry about
it we're just going to go over that
while be killing this thing and then
finally I'm just going to have
description inside here and I'm going to
say give it a far char of 255 which
means I'm setting a max character of 255
we just wrote our commands and now you
should already have installed Postgres
so let me just put this aside so I'm
going to open this command line right
here so you should already installed it
and then what you're going to run is P
SQL - you are presenting as a user and
we're going to be using them user
Postgres so if pain time you installed
Postgres you automatically have a user
by default called Postgres which is a
super admin and a super admin has full
access to everything and then it's going
to tell me what's my password and that's
what you wrote inside your installation
process so when you install postgrads
it told you to put a password inside
there so we're gonna put it inside here
okay so I'm inside my database so let's
kind of run through the commands that I
was talking about when I do slash L it
is going to show me all of my databases
so for example if it still look amazing
essentially all of these little things
that you see over here on the side is
representing each of these databases
okay so once I have this thing down I
could do ctrl C to get out of this
really quick okay and then inside here
I'm going to see that have JWT off so
I'm going to move inside that database
so i'm going to say slash c JWT off base
so now as you can see here it's saying
that you're connected to the database
GWT off as user Postgres okay and then I
can look at all the tables that's inside
there by simply seeing /dt so
this case this has a single user table
okay awesome so now we're going to make
our own database so I'm gonna go inside
here I'm gonna grab this command and I'm
gonna put it right there
and check this out it's going to say
need to be straight or Freight database
and then once we have that down we can
do slash out you can see you're right
there that we in have indeed added it to
our database or a tool or Postgres I'm
gonna do ctrl C again to get out of here
and then I'm going to move inside there
so slash C into burn to do so you can
see it does the same as like process and
now I'm gonna run /dt to see what or not
we have any tables you can see here it
says did not find any relations so now
we take this thing right here and then
we put it right there okay so awesome so
we created a table and now if I do /dt
you can see that indeed we have created
a table called to do now I think it's
also worth mentioning that you don't
have to call this to do ID you can also
call this tea ideas wall so I'm just
gonna show you this command later but
essentially it's going to get all of my
to-do see that right here is what we
define our schema ass to do ID and
description and like I said again
doesn't have to be to do ID
I'm just being explicit some people just
like to say T ID or you can do whatever
you want with that okay so in the next
section we're going to connect our
database with our server
okay so let's start connecting
everything together so connecting like
our database before server is really
easy when we use the PG library so what
I'm going to go is create a file called
dbaas
and this is going to configured how
we're going to connect to our database
so i'm gonna say cops pull require PG
library so remember we install the PG
library adopt pull and now the can
instances fall by same cons pull equals
to Newell pool and now we can set up our
configurations inside here so what's
inside we have the first specify our
user so in this case we're going to be
using the Postgres user and then we have
to define a password as well so kate
hlaa to choose of mine we also have to
say what the host is which is going to
be localhost and then we are also going
to specify our port which is going to
automatically run on port 5 4 3 2 and
then which is also very important we
also have to specify the database which
is going to be turned to do because as
you can see here we created this
database called prone to do and that's
the database we're going to be using so
awesome that's all it takes to connect
to our database so I'm just going to
export this guy so that module dot
exports and then pull ok so since that's
all set up for us I'm gonna go back into
our index set yes and I'm going to
require that so by using the pool we can
run queries with Postgres oh my god
what's happening
dot slash DB there you go okay and just
kind of give us a heads up I'm just
going to start writing the routes that
we're going to be working with with this
pool query stuff so the first one is
that we want to create a to do next one
I want to get all to do this get paid to
do update a to do and finally I want to
delete a to do so we're going to work on
each of these routes and we're going to
be using this new connection that we
have over here to run queries with our
Postgres so I'll see you then
all right so let's start building some
routes so right off the bat we're gonna
start with creating to do let's do this
we're gonna say app that posts the
reason it's going to be post is because
we're adding data and I'm going to name
Israel as to Do's
okay and I'm going to run free rekka res
which represents requests from the
client side and response we're going to
send back to the client and then I'm
going to use async now the great thing
about async by using this we're allowed
to get these really cool tools that
makes asynchronous requests easy so for
example anytime we're creating data over
trying to get data it's going to take
some time so async provides us something
call wait which waits for the function
to complete before it continues okay so
you have to see that pretty soon so then
we also have try-catch which makes our
error handling so much more easier the
reason for that is because it's going to
run a regular code and any time I finds
an error it's going to catch it and it's
going to throw it out and this is how
our basic error handling is going to be
done okay so now that's done inside here
I need to be able to get data from the
client side to determine what exactly
I'm going to add so remember how I said
we need to do something called Express
not Jason so I just kind of added a
comment over here that's going to let us
add request that body so by using this
we can access this object right there
and if you don't know what it is I can
just console dot log that thing I should
have give you guys a heads up but I am
going to be using postman postman it's
great when it comes to wanting to test
your applications or your restful api's
so in this case I'm going to create
something new you can see right off here
that we have all these different types
of HDB that we can use so in this case
we're going to be using posts and I also
need to specify that I want to hit the
slash to do rounds so let me do this
really quick so I'm going to say HTTP
slash localhost
5,000 and in / - duze okay and now
remember how we can access this request
stop body so I'm going to go inside it's
a body right here I'm gonna say raw and
I'm gonna specify it's going to JSON and
then I'm going to create a JSON data so
in this case remember we're working on
description some
gonna see description is I need to clean
my room so now if I click send we look
inside here you can see indeed it pops
up right there description I need to
clean my room and this is exactly the
data that we're going to use to save it
within our database okay so hopefully
that clears things up so remember we
have this description that I'm going to
be using so I'm going to D structure
back I'm gonna say constant description
in a request that body okay so time for
some actual queries so I'm going to say
Kant's new to do and then I'm going to
see a weight pull top query so remember
that pulse what we just create it right
there and now we're going to start
reading some queries so in order for
this thing to work in order to add data
we have to use the insert into command
so insert into and then after that we
have to specify which table we're trying
to insert into we're just going to be to
do and then we have to specify what type
of column are trying to add data into so
in this case we have a simple
description and then we have to specify
the values of that and this is going to
look a little bit weird at first but
we're gonna have something called dollar
signs one so what is this this is going
to be a placeholder or essentially going
to be a variable that's going to specify
this description so we're going to have
the second argument sign is query which
is going to define this dollar sign one
so remember how we have the description
which is coming from a client side I'm
gonna put it right inside here how our
description is going to be the value of
this dollar sign one okay so if it's
still a little bit confusing don't worry
about it let me just risk juicing this
and I'll explain it again okay so I'm
gonna do this really quick and now I'm
going to open my postman one more time
and I'm gonna try to hit it
you can see we had a status of 200 and
don't be scared but you're gonna see a
lot of gibberish you see all of these
things but this indicates that we have
done something successful so if we look
inside our database and I say select all
from to do like I said again you don't
have to know this command yet I'm gonna
explain it later but you could see that
indeed that we have added that data
inside our database so pretty cool and
look you don't have to set it as dollar
sign one that's just the PG library
allowing us to add dynamic data we can
actually just do it straight inside here
so for example I can just say it like
insert into to do depression because I'm
trying to hit this column right there I
also have to specify the values of this
guy and I'm going to say single quotes
like let's just say hello for example
and then that's all I could do so you
can see I inserted the data and if I
decided to see what's inside there again
you can see it that I have added hello
it's nice and you also see that we are
incrementing this thing one two we
didn't do that but because remember we
set serial primary key is going to
automatically increase it to ensure that
we have uniqueness all right so
hopefully that made more sense as you
can see here that this dollar sign one
is just going to allow us to put in some
variables of what we're trying to add
database so you can see that we have all
of this ugly thing over here so we want
to make sure we're returning back the
data so what we have to do is say
returning returning star so returning
star is used whenever you're inserting
data or you're updating or deleting so
anytime you're doing these type of
actions you're wanting to return back
the data so let me show you again we go
inside here and I try to hit this route
you'll see we'll get something different
so you see this we have now all of this
data and you can see that this is the
data that we just add it inside there I
need to clean my room to do ID 3 and we
want to just hit this Rose right there
because we don't want to see all these
other things so inside I'm just gonna
say new to do that rose and then I'm
going to hit the first item so now I'm
going to hit it one more
I guess I should change it up a little
bit and this is good for us because we
are really we're gonna in the next route
we're just going to try to get these two
dues so now if we go to the bottom you
can see we have something that's a lot
more easier to read so awesome okay so
we create our to do next we want to see
all our two dues and this one's really
easy and if you're gonna memorize it
right off the bat so I'm gonna see up
that get because we're just simply
wanting to get the it up I'm gonna see /
- dues and then I'm gonna do the same
process request the rest I'm gonna use
this acing stuff try-catch so this is
really my regular convention that I like
doing how it's without error --air about
message and then inside here what we're
going to do is we're going to be saying
kant's all today's a weight is gonna
take some time
pull that query guess this select so
remember we use select oh my god I could
spell it select all from to do and
that's all we have to do really so
remember how I kept running this command
just to see my two dues this is exactly
the same as that command so now I can
save rest I'll Jason wanted use remember
it's gonna be in this row stuff the only
reason why I don't have to see returning
stars because the purpose of select is
to even give us the data back so we
don't have to say returning star so
let's check this thing out so I'm gonna
go inside here and I want to see all of
my to dues so I'm gonna make a get
request and check this out how cool is
that so now we have all these different
to do that we just create it and we can
we can just spin it out by simply
running this command
alright so pretty simple so in the next
step we are now wanting to still get it
to do so still gonna have this thing but
we want to get a specific to do so it's
still gonna be a packet cuz we're
getting data now I'm gonna say /c dues
and I'm going to also do : ID so what is
that we just finished this really quick
just the basic setup
a try/catch air console air air that
message okay so what is this thing
essentially this allows our our URL to
beta dot is it's going to allow our URL
to be dynamic so we have access now to
something called console dot blog to
request that perhaps so whatever the
client specifies in URL it's going to
spit this out with the variable of ID so
it's a little confusing so let me show
you what I mean
so I'm gonna go back inside here you can
see that we're gonna try to hit this
route so I can say slash the dues and
then I can just write something random
so I'll indeed that's what I'm going to
write look inside here if I click enter
you can see that we have an ID of random
and this is actually coming from this
area right here you can see we specify
ID I don't have to call it this I can
just name it whatever I want and if I
save this and I enter it again it's
going to do the same exact process so
subject random okay so hopefully that
makes sense because that's what we're
going to be using the specify what type
of to do we want to get so you're gonna
see later on we're going to specify it
as one two three
you name it so let me just change this
back to its regular form
and uh yeah okay so now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to be structure this
so Kant's ID from request aapke programs
and then now I'm gonna try to get this
idea so Khan studio and I'm gonna see
you wait because it's going to take some
time
hold that query now select all firm to
do okay and now I'm going to introduce a
new player which is called the where
clause and the where Clause specifies
what type of to do we actually we
actually want sorry about that
well exactly we want so in this case I'm
going to specify the column to do ID is
remember we named it in sight database
that SQL and we're gonna say what where
the to do ID equals to dollar sign one
and I'm going to specify it with the ID
reason why this is important is because
I can specify this esta Deuce and I want
to get the one so it's going to say
select all to do swear the to do ID
equals to one two or three
so you'll see this in action real soon
and then I'm going to simply say Breslau
JSON to do that rose and I'm gonna get
the first item because we're just
getting one to do all right let's see
that really quick so in this case you
can see that we have all our deduce
right here and I want to get number
three so I you know what let's do number
four
so if I say click here you can see that
we get our specific data so nice so by
using a where class we can be specific
on what we're trying to get ok pretty
simple and we're gonna work on the next
route which is going to update a to do
this one is probably a little bit more
complex from the rest but still not as
bad so since we're updating information
I'm gonna say app that put I'm going to
specify it as to do's and it's going to
be ID so the reason I need is specify ID
because I want to know what exactly or
what should you I need to update then
I'm gonna run a sync so the regular
stuff and then what I'm going to be
doing inside here ok so what I'm going
to be doing inside here is I need to
have two things remember we have access
to be requests our body to get
information about the description that
we're trying to add to a database and we
also have across the params to specify
what type of to do we want so we're
going to need both of them in order to
update and explain why so we have ID
over here or post-op drams and then
we're going to have const over here
which is going to be what is it yeah
description quest stop body it's awesome
we're gonna be using these tools to
update your information so here's how
the query works I'm gonna seek constant
update to do and then I'm going to do a
weight again pull that query and now
this is the craving I'm going to run I'm
gonna say update I have to do I have to
run update and I have to specify the
table so update and to do stable and
then I have to run set so what do I set
I have this ugly description call lump
to whatever I specified a right fit
actually set the description to the
description that's specified right side
and then I also have to specify where
it's located at so I had to say where
it's a do ID equals to dollar sign to
what
so this may look a little confusing but
remember how I said these represent
variables so we don't have to just do
dollar sign one we can do a lemonade
mouths like you can even go up to like
dollar sign 100 if you need to write but
basically these are just variable
holders so all I have to do is go inside
my second argument array specify the
first value which is going to be
description so this is representing this
one right there and then I have to
create a comma right here and specify ID
so this ID is coming from here and it's
going to represent this dollar sign too
okay and now I can just do rent a sin
and I'm just gonna keep this simple I'm
just going to say to do was updated okay
so let's see how this is going to work
so I'm going to go inside here I'm going
to try to change I need to clean my car
so let's go up here really quick and
let's say let's I need to clean my floor
so now I have to change this the foot
because I'm trying to update this and
now if I click enter hopefully it works
you can see a status of 200 and indeed
to do was update it so let's just double
check to make sure it did so if I go in
say slash four and I look into the
bottom oops I have to make this to again
request
it does change so it says I need to
clean my floor so cool we were able to
update our information and if you're
still confused like I said again I'm
going to do a quick review over all the
queries we just did and finally we have
deleted to do which is really easy it's
exactly kind of like the get request so
what we're going to be doing is app that
delete is we're deleting data slash
induce and all we could do is specify
the ID in the regular process because
that res try to catch that's all done
and ready to go we don't have to add
data to a delete so all we have to do is
specify what a sock that we want to
delete Hey
and aside there we're going to say
Kant's delete to do and we're gonna do
the same process a weight pull that
query and I'm going to say delete from
so I'm going to run this command delete
from and we to specify in the to do
stable and then all we have to do left
is say where it's located at so where
are the to do ID equals to dollar sign
and that is just going to be as you
guessed it ID and then we're just going
to do another breast that jason and just
say to do was delete it
so congratulations will actually no we
can't say that yet until we test this
out so let's make sure that we can
actually delete this one right here so
in this case I wanted to leet that fake
sample that I created over here
so hello so I'm gonna say slash to
specify it's going to be a delete
request because remember I specified ask
delete and now if I click enter to do
what's deleted and let's make sure it
does get to leave it
oops it could get requests check this
out it was to leave it okay so clear our
relations you officially created a
restful api of Postgres so in the next
section I'm just gonna do a quick
overview of the queries we did so you
can have a better picture of what
happened so I'll see you then
all right so congratulations for
building a RESTful API with Postgres so
I'm just gonna give you guys a quick
review because I want the cerulean green
in your mind so as you can see inside
here we had a basic server that we set
up and then we did something called
database that SQL so this mean I'm more
visually pleasing for us to write our
commands again you don't have to do it
this way you can just put it directly
inside the command line so what we did
was create table prior to do and then we
created a well sorry not create table we
created a database called prayer to you
and then we create a table within that
database called to do and we had to find
two things inside there the first we
defined was the description which was
given a max character of 255 and then we
set something called to do ID the
primary key and the reason why it's so
important is because we want to ensure
uniqueness between all our other two
dews because if you want to delete
update or get a specific to do it we'll
have to reference something that
distinguishes the rest of the other two
dews which in this case to do ID and
then you see primary key indicates that
this to do ID is what makes it unique
and then we have the serial function
which automatically increases the
primary key to ensure that's unique as
you can see inside here that's what
happened 1 to 2 now in order to connect
to it it was as easy as taking the
library so required PG that pool and
then we just had to configure where and
how we were going to connect to it in
this case we have to specify the user
the password the host which is localhost
because it's running on our local
machine our port by default postcode
runs on 4 4 3 2 and then our database
which was purred to do so as you can see
what the reason we connected to purge
adduce because that's what we specified
ok so now when we go to index entry yes
we started to create some routes so
whenever you're creating something
inside Postgres you have to use the
insert into command okay so the insert
into command specifies the table that
you want to insert something in and the
column which is going to be the
description and then you have to enter
in what that value of the subscription
is going to be in this case we had
dollar sign 1 which was really strange
for a lot of people who just started but
essentially this is just a simple
placeholder and this value is going to
be specified in the second argument
ray which is going to be description so
this description is going to represent
this dollar sign one over there okay and
then and also it's worth mentioning that
all of these different commands that you
see here these queries that I'm having
over here can just simply be run inside
the command line themself and also we
have returning start because we were
adding data so we want to get back that
data again so anytime you're trying to
insert or you're trying to update or
delete you have to use returning star to
show what exactly you're using and then
we had to do Reza Jason not rose because
that's where the data is located at
finally inside here we just had to do
select all from studios and this allows
us to get all the to-do from that table
right there and as you can see here you
don't have to specify stars I don't know
if I was specific on this but it doesn't
have to always be select star stars just
simply there to say that we want to get
everything so if I go to my command line
and I say select and so star I could say
description from to do I just get the
description so I can be specific on what
I'm trying to get so instead of actually
trying to pass everything to the client
site I can just minimize that and just
pass what I really need to pass over to
the client side and then we just
suppress that Jason that data and
insight here we introduced a new player
called the where clause and the word
Clause allows us to be more specific on
what we're trying to do so in this case
remember we are trying to get all to
deuce but only were the to do ID equals
to what we specified in the client side
so we're gonna say we're specify the
column and then the number the equals
two then we worked an update which was a
tiny bit more complex but it was still
nice and easy to work with so we have to
use the update command specify the table
and then we have to use set describe the
column that we're trying to change so we
set that equal to the description define
and the client side and then we have to
specify where that to do we want to
updated what's going to be located at so
we have to say where to do ID equals to
whatever you specified inside there
okay and already you can see we have
dollar sign one dollar sign to you you
can go up to any dollar signs you want
to it's just that inside your array you
just have to specify it inside there so
if I added a dollar sign three I will
have to add it inside this array as well
of what that equals to and then finally
delete which was really easy all we had
to do was specified delete from command
specified the table and see where was
located at okay so we used that word
clause again so pretty simple stuff so
congratulations so in the next section
we are going to start creating our
client side so just so you guys can see
I'm just going to create you turn them
over here and then I'm going to say MPX
create react app and I'm going to find
it as client okay
so after this team finish loading we'll
just start building our application
all right so as you can see my client
side has finished loading so before I
even like to jump in to clean this thing
up I just want to show you guys quickly
if this diagram again and the different
components that were going to be working
with so let me just kind of zoom in a
little bit so remember we're going to be
having three components to this
front-end so we're gonna have first a
input component then we're gonna have a
component that's going to show all the
two dues didn't last we're gonna have a
component that's going to open our edit
modal okay so let's get started so I'm
gonna go back inside here and I'm just
gonna clean some things up so we don't
really need these anymore well we're
gonna need them eventually but let's
just focus on the client side so I'm
gonna go inside here and I'm just going
to clean some things that we don't need
so in this case we don't need this you
also don't need this logo SVG I'm also
gonna get rid of these service set up
tests all right and then we're gonna go
to index @gs clean all these things out
really quick right along the server
worker you don't need that anymore and
then I'm gonna go to app that GS and I'm
just going to get rid of this load of
stuff so we don't have any errors and
I'm just going to take in the fragment
and I'm just gonna clean this all out we
don't need these things anymore all
right I'm gonna put fragments ID there
and there we go and just to make it even
better we're just going to create a new
folder called components so we're gonna
talk about the street components we just
did so we're gonna do new file remember
we're gonna have a search input so input
to do a Jas then I'm going to make
another component which is going to list
all over to do is study GS and then
finally I'm going to make a new file
that's going to have the Edit to do
that's pretty much the setup for
components right now and also we are
going to be using bootstrap for so let
me kind of get that set up for you guys
as well so go inside here bootstrap for
then we're just going to open this thing
up and just go down here take the CSS
and we're gonna put it inside our public
index that HTML so I'm gonna just put my
link probably right here maybe you want
to you can just get rid of all these
comments they're not going to help us
really and finally we are going to be
using a mortal so I'm gonna take this on
this data right here and then I'm gonna
put it all right there which oh yeah
right there I'm gonna put it near the
body okay so pretty neat okay so that's
pretty much your setup so the next
section we're gonna start building the
inputs you
all righty so let's get started so I
already went to my client folder and I
did NPM start to get everything ready so
let's go inside our input to do and
let's start setting some things up so
I'm going to start saying import react
from react and then I'm gonna make a
simple component just to get enough on
the board I'm going to return assemble
each one that's going to be input to do
and I'm going to export default list now
I'm going to require it within my app
that GS so let's go inside here and I'm
just going to add a comment that's going
to say the components and it's going to
say import input to do from the slash
component slash input to do all right
now I'm just gonna put it right there
all right and now if I'm looking over
here you'll see that I have input to do
and it's a little bit too close on the
side so I'm going to make sure that I
space this thing out with like a teener
okay I over here and I'm gonna put it oh
no not there
I'm gonna put it right there and it
should be a lot more spacious so yeah
that's a little bit better and I kind of
want to make that to the middle so let's
go into input to do and now we can start
doing some real things we're gonna make
a fragment and I'm going to put a
fragment right here and now I'm gonna
put my h1 Aspern to do unless okay and
I'm gonna add a classmate of Tech Center
and I'm also going to add a margin top
of 5 is it is you can see if it's a
little bit too close so it looks nice
for us and the last thing we need to do
next is that we need to create a form
because we are going to submit something
new so I'm gonna create a form over here
you don't need this action mm-hmm and
I'm going to have input right here
I put text I'm gonna keep it like that
and then I'm going to have a button
that's going to say add so let's see how
that looks like pretty ugly so we can
make that look a little bit better so
last name I'm gonna add a BTN will not
be T in there but I'm gonna say for
control for here that should make it a
little bit better okay and right on the
back you see it's kind of knocking the
ad out
so let's just kind of decorate that as
well so I'm just gonna say class mean
BTN PT and success and then after that
I'm gonna add a D flex because this
thing goes 100% I want them to be
together
now as you can see now it's going to be
put together it's awesome and it's still
a little bit tight so I guess I'm gonna
add a margin top 5 there as well we're
just really abusing this margin top 5
yeah that looks a lot better okay so now
it's time for us to react to phi this
thing you want to start containing our
state within this so i am going to be
using react hooks so I'm gonna use new
state and it's site here we're gonna put
on the top so I'm going to say Kant's
and I'm going to say let's see let's
call description and then we're gonna
say set description and I'm going to set
it to you state and add a default value
of an empty string now if you don't
understand this basically this is our
state and this right here is the only
way to change the state and then we have
new state to show our default value so
now I'm gonna go to my input we're gonna
set the value to that steep that I have
a bear just description so just to prove
my point that this is our deep over
there
I'm just gonna add something like for
example hello so now if you look inside
there you'll see by default we have a
hello inside there okay we can't change
it because we don't have an on change
yet so I'm gonna open this thing up and
what I'm going to do next is that I want
to change or update the description so
I'm gonna say unchanged
and I'm gonna use D for event and it's
going to do set description to Eva
target so it's going to target whatever
is in that input and it's going to get
as a result the value of it okay yeah
that target done value so now if i just
type inside this thing and you just add
random values and it's going to update
and if we want to get rid of that hello
because we don't start to that okay so
pretty neat so we have this react stuff
set up next we want to be able to submit
our form to send data out so how do we
do this let's create a function that's
gonna call on submit form so I'm just
going to know yeah I'll just make this
error function and right there
I'm gonna use my try catch again so I
gotta use the async stuff and I'm gonna
set this to error so console dot error
error that message and I'm gonna put an
e inside here because it's going to send
an event and we don't want this name to
refresh so I'm going to say either
prevent default now inside here is where
we're gonna start like sending a request
so I'm going to package this description
over here so I'm gonna say con spot e
equals to description I'm eating it all
up so normally you'll have a lot more
than just a simple description if you're
building a complex application but in
this case I'm just gonna keep it like
this
and then I'm going to say cons for
sponsor and I'm going to start sending a
request to add data so I'm gonna say
fetch so I'm gonna use the fetch I'm
going to specify HTTP slash slash and
localhost
so I'm trying to add data so remember
happy go slash seduce so by default
fetch makes a get request so we have to
add some more configurations so I'm
going to set inside here that our method
is actually going to be a post request
ok and what I'm going to be sending
assign there is going to be JSON data so
I just have to set the headers to high
and the content type is going to be a
result of applica
/ whoops let me get rid of that / JSON
okay and then finally I have to what am
I going to be sending over there so I
have to have a bot I'm gonna have to
stringify this package it all up
shooting the Phi and then I have to
stringify that body over there alright
looks pretty solid
so let's kind of test to see where this
works and I'm just gonna go console dot
log response see if everything works
well now you should have your server on
because we're gonna start interacting
with it right now so let's go over here
it I'm going to say okay so we open my
little console I'm gonna clear all this
so it can be a little easier to read
let's say I need to wash the dishes so
now if I click Add let's hope it works
wait I just noticed this thing just
refreshed okay so that's a problem
because oh yeah cuz I didn't connect to
my forum yet okay so yeah we have to do
that first so to see on submit so this
is going to be triggered when it's
submitted and then I'm going to run on
submit form and now it should be working
I'm gonna go over here and I'm just
going to write in my data like now I
need to wash the dishes
doing a promise and that's what I
totally forgot so remember when you're
making a fetch request it's going to
take some time so we need to await you
don't wait for this thing to finish and
then we can console download that
response so now and I hope finally this
thing is gonna start working again it's
just a working progress so no problem at
all and I'm just gonna write I you know
I'm just gonna say hello give this up
and I'm just gonna add it and cool
we had a status of 200 so let's make
sure we really did get that data so open
up your command line over here psql uh
she you so the regular process again he
teached let2 and then i'm gonna go into
that herd to do stuff that we created
and I'm gonna say select all from to do
I'm gonna determine what or not I
actually have it and look at that
I'm at the data over here and I wasn't
able to add the other one that's neat
so you can see how low was Eric if I
decide to add another data
let's check this out really quick cool
it works so we're able to add data ok so
since that's all set up in the next
section we're going to start working on
the list to do so we can display all our
information
so I just realized I wasn't complete of
this component instead of saying console
dot log response I actually want to do
window that location slash
so once the response has been sent it's
going to refresh and show the changes
okay so make sure you change it to this
next I'm going to go inside list seduce
and create that component an import
react from react then I'm going to say
constant list adduce and I'm just going
to be returning something really simple
just get us started and I'm gonna call
it list to do x' and then I'm just going
to export default this guy okay so that
should be all set up and now I'm gonna
go to my app that genius again and I'm
going to import that that slash componet
slash what does it called again let's to
do this and I'm just gonna put it right
under here and we'll see whether or not
it does pop up alright so let's go
inside here let's see if it pops up over
there let's - dear should be right there
awesome so now we can do some real
damage or sorry no not real damage we
can do some real stuff so I'm gonna take
in some fragments and I'm gonna go
inside here it's a fragment and now I'm
going to take in a table so I'm gonna
use bootstrap forest tables so I'm just
gonna go into w3schools so I already
have it set up right here if you want to
get to where I'm at simply what I did
was I just wrote w3 school which
bootstrap 4 tables and the first thing
that's going to pop up is this basic
table so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to grab this table tak over
here to the end of the other table tag
I'm gonna copy that
and I'm gonna take it and I'm gonna put
it right inside of there okay and I can
see there might be some confusion so
just to don't check around the same page
right w3 school bootstrap for poor table
ok and then you should be at this
location as I am and then you could just
click on this thing right here and
you'll be lead to so I'm gonna start
using w3schools and I'm just gonna copy
their codes and just put it directly
into here to make our process a lot
faster so now if we look into a react
application you can see that we have our
table and we're just gonna clean this up
a little bit more so first of all you
can see it was a little bit too close so
again we're gonna do a margin top 5 and
I kind of want to do text center that as
well and we don't want to have first
name last name or email we want to first
display the description and then I want
to display the edit button and finally I
want to display a delete button now we
don't need these other ideas but I am
gonna keep going for reference so when I
map each of the data once I fetch it I
want to be able to know how I should
structure it so I'm gonna take John Doe
then inside there and I'm just going to
delete the rest all right so let's see
how that looks like I should be a lot
more cleaner ok so let's get started so
I am going to be using a few things I'm
going to be using use effect and I'm
also going to be using these state so
these stuff are going to help us with a
process to use effect is going to make a
fetch request two of us will api's every
time this component is rendered ok so
I'm gonna go inside here I'm gonna write
use effect and I'm gonna write a
function that's going to hit this one so
it's gonna say KITT to do is create it
yet so I'm gonna create it at the top so
I'm gonna get error and yeah I'll just
do an error function again so get to do
is a sink sorry now I have to break a
sink and this is going to equal to try
catch and
gonna console dot log the error that
message and let me just change this the
air it's a bit better alright and then
inside here we're going to make another
fetch request so I'm gonna say cost
response equals to a weight so remember
we're gonna make a fetch request right
here to HTTP slash localhost
5,000 / to do's and by default fetch
makes a get request so that's we can
just keep it like this
then next I'm going to get some data
back but I can't just simply console
don't log it I need to parse it so we're
gonna be getting JSON data back so I
have to say kant's let's say JSON data
and then I'm going to say response dot
JSON so I'm going to have to parse it
first because we're getting JSON data
and then now I can console
jin-suk data so let's see what we get as
a results so let's go inside here and
let's check this out oops I almost
forgot as well did it does take some
time to parse data so we have to say
wait for this as well so things should
start working once again so cool look at
that we get all our data from there so
now we can utilize this array and we can
put it inside our you state so we're
gonna create a state right here we're
gonna see Kant's and let's just call
these to do this I'm gonna say set to do
this and I'm gonna give it a default
value of just an empty array and after
that I'm going to set that JSON data
into there so I'm gonna say set to do
this because that's the only way to
change the state and then I'm going to
print cite JSON data okay so in case you
don't know what's going to be inside
there we can double check and I could
just run console dot log to do this so
this is our state so let's see what we
get from there
so as you can see we're making a lot of
requests and that's pretty cuz the thing
about use effect is that it just keeps
on like making requests once the render
happens
so an ensure that we only make one
request I'm gonna go inside here and I'm
just gonna put like this so this is
going to only it make it do one request
and now you can see that our state that
we just constant all log as all the data
so now we can start mapping all of these
things and just spit it out so I'm gonna
open this thing right here I'm going to
get rid of this console dot log and
we're gonna start mapping so remember
how I had to reference this thing so I'm
going to use the same exact structure so
I'm going to say to dues that map some
we're gonna happen to do and I am going
to structure it as TR as remember it's
like this and then the first TD is going
to be the results of to do dot
description how did I get this because
if you look inside here remember if I
open my console and I look at the data
that we have so I have to refresh this
Oh woops sorry let me console that long
this again so at least you guys can
understand how I'm getting these data so
I'm just gonna console dot blog to do
and then if we look inside here you can
see that we are going to be able to get
access to the description so let's do
that really quick so I'm gonna see to do
that description and if finally I'm just
gonna add a TD that's going to have edit
and then I'm also gonna have a TD that's
going to stay delete these are going to
eventually be buttons but at the
meantime we're just gonna be focusing on
mapping data and now if you look into
here hello we're able to list all our
descriptions and then we have
potentially our buttons that we're going
to be using to edit information and to
delete so in the next section we're
gonna start focusing on deleting and
then later on editing
okay so let's start focusing on our
delete button over here so I'm gonna
start opening this thing up and I'm
gonna go to the bottom of this delete
button right here and I'm going to try
to make it to a real button so I'm gonna
say button put in and it's going to say
delete and I'm going to add a class name
of BTN and BTN danger so it looks like a
real danger button okay so that should
make it look a little bit better there
we go oops let me get rid of that little
sign over there okay so now things
should you have a little bit better so
thing about the leap button is that I
want to have it happy I'm clicked so
when I click on this thing it's going to
specify the ID that I'm trying to delete
from this specific to do and then it's
going to make a fetch request to delete
that data so let me explain Haley what
you're seeing here is that I need to
list all my unique keys and the reason
this is happening is because it wants to
make sure all my to do is are unique so
if I go inside here I can simply say he
and remember my to do that to do ID is
what makes my to do so unique so in the
same concepts I can use this to do ID
and put it inside here so what I'm going
to do is that I'm going to say on click
and I'm going to create a function
that's going to whoops we're going to
create a function that's going to be
called the leap to do and it is going to
take an argument of that to do IDs so we
can specify what a cycle we want to
delete so I'm gonna put inside here to
do that to do ID okay and now I'm going
to start defining it so you see we
really have air that's being spit out so
let's go to the top things are starting
to get a tiny bit messy so I'll just
kind of my comment here that was going
to be pleat delete function I'm gonna
say cost elite
it's going to also make asynchronous
requests okay I'm gonna do try catch
error console care and that message okay
in a site here we're going to make a
fetch request specifically a delete
fetch request in order to delete that
specific to do in our restful api so
what I'm going to do is say taunts
delete to do and a member we're having
an argument site here so I'm gonna put
ID inside here so I'm gonna say delete
to do and I'm going to say a weight and
it's gonna be a fetch request queue HTTP
slash localhost 5,000 to do's and then
we have to specify the ID over here so
in this case I'm going to make some
template shrinks and essentially
template shrinks allows you to put
variables within your your strings so
I'm gonna add dollar sign and I'm going
to add that ID over there so remember
I'm going to go to dues and I'm going to
delete the ID that's specified as the
argument that passed inside there okay
so now to make sure that we are truly
doing this oh I almost forgot that I
also have to configure this as a delete
so I'm gonna add an object over here
and I'm gonna say the method is going to
be delete okay and that's all I'm going
to be doing it should ensure that
everything is working all right let's
just do console.log delete to do to see
that what or not it was successful
website here let's go for let's say for
example this one so let's say I click
delete and you can see that we have a
status of 200 so this was I need to
clean my room so let's make sure we
deleted that should delete this one
right there
so cool we delete the information so
that's all we need to do to delete
information and in the next section oh
sorry no not in the next section the
thing is is that I want to be able to
instantly get rid of this I don't want
to keep refresh
because you can see it's still there and
after i refresh it then it's going to go
away right there's one less clean my
room so to ensure that we don't have to
do this I prefer to use a filter so what
I'm going to be setting because I'm
going to say set to deuce and I'm going
to grab that to do state than I have
over there I'm going to say to dues and
then I'm going to do a filter so filter
essentially sets up a condition and if
the deduce like fit that condition then
it's only kind of returning those that
qualified so I'm going to say to do and
I'm going to say if the to do that to do
IDs so I'm going all need to do studio
IDs does not equal to that to do or to
that idea that I specified inside my
argument then spit those out so it's
going to spit every other to do except
the ones that I'm trying to delete so
you'll see what I'm gonna do pretty soon
so let's go inside here check this out
so I have all these data I could just
delete okay yeah that so I could delete
all these information and it's going to
shorten my array and we can look inside
here that the information was deleted so
cool so in the next section we're going
to start editing your information
all right so let's start working on
editing information so I decided to just
have a clean start so let's say I need
to clean my room again and I'm just
gonna add that really quick so we could
edit something Elise and I'll just add a
second item between my four very
creative okay so now that's all set up
so I'm just going to go inside my edit
to do and I'm just going to make a
simple component then I'm just going to
say cons edit to do I'm just gonna
return a simple h1 that's going to save
edit to do and it I'm just going to
export default bot instead of putting it
inside the app that GES I'm going to be
putting it in site list to do so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go to
the top of this and then I'm going to
import that so I'm gonna say import edit
to do from now / edit to do and now I
can go to the bottom right here and
instead of having that edit button or
that edit text being displayed I can put
it inside that deponent so now let's see
what this looks like okay so we have two
very big ones but at least we know it's
going to be working so now we can do
some real things with this edit to do
component so I'm gonna open this
fragments and we're just gonna put it
right here
hey so let's go back into w3schools
and then we're going to so if you can
join me we can write w3schools bootstrap
for and immortal I already have it all
set up and then you can click on this
and the first thing you're going to see
is this blue button which is exactly
what we need because if we click on it
we want to display a modal so I'm going
to take all of this data right here and
then I'm going to go to my edit to do
and I am going to spit it in here and
you're gonna get an error so we just get
rid of all these comments
all right and mobile Heather needs to go
away too and I think nope there's one
more all right so now if i refresh this
or if I save it
EDA should be different so if we look
inside here you'll see that we have you
put it so right here we can like open
things up so I'm gonna change this to an
edit button and I'm just going to modify
this by having emitter edit button here
along with an input so we can edit let's
see if that so instead of open model I'm
gonna say edit and then I'm gonna go
down here and say you didn't instead of
normal body I'm gonna have a simple
input input type of text we'll just keep
it like that for now and then and also I
think I should add a class named control
to make it look a little bit better and
then a member I want to have a edit
button besides the close button so I'm
gonna take that and I'm gonna put it
right there call it edit and this is
going to be a red so I want to make this
morning keep it consistent I'm also
going to make this warning as well so
let's see how this looks like so we go
inside here you'll see that this looks
just so much a little bit it looks a
little bit better than our last one so
now we could put in some data and then
we can click Edit to edit the
information so currently at the moment
this description doesn't have any
correlation with this edit model so we
need to pass that props inside this edit
component so remember in listed OU's you
are just mapping all those different
types of views so we can add that as a
prop or edit to do component so I'm just
gonna add to the insight here now we
have this for a disposal so go to edit
to do and let's add site here to do
because it's a prop when you structure
it and to ensure that we're on the same
page console dot log to do to see what
I'm talking about
so they open my my inspect you see what
I'm talking about see now each of these
items have access to each of these
entities have access to these things so
you can see that this one goes with I
need to clean it room and then this one
right here goes with that it's like an
item right there alright so we're gonna
open this back up and now I want to be
able to display it so I'm gonna have to
keep track of it so I'm gonna take a new
state and now I'm going to save Kant's
description and then I'm gonna say set
description because I want to set a new
description later on and a new state so
I'm not going to set it to your empty
string but rather since I already have
this to do I'm going to set it by
default to do to do a description reason
for this because I want to edit the
information so I really need to know
what's already there and then what I'm
going to do next is I'm going to set the
value to that gonna be a description so
let's check this out really quick look
inside here you'll see that I need to
clean my room but you're also going to
notice something really strange is that
if I click on this it's going to say I
need to clean my room as well it's not I
need to clean my floor now the reason
for that is because the correlations are
wrong so a mobile works this way when
you click on a button it's going to
target a specific ID and then in this
case this IDs my modal so it's always
going to be opening this modal so we
need to ensure that each of these
buttons and each of these models are
unique so let's make sure that these
things are different and the best way to
make sure it's unique is we can use that
to do to do ID so let's do that really
quick so I'm just gonna use the numbers
now you can't just use numbers with your
IDs so you also need to put like a
string on top of that so I'll do that
really quick so I'm gonna say template
strings and I'm gonna say ID and then
I'm gonna add that to do that to you ID
so this is what it's going to look like
in case you're still a little confused
what's happening like do it like this
essentially what I'm writing is going to
be ID is going to equal to ID and then
it's going to be whatever number we
specified so it's gonna look like that
and then we're going to target that so
I'm gonna go inside here I'm going to
say a dollar sign this and I'm going to
say oops sorry not dollar sign yet let
me get rid of this and we're gonna run a
template string and I'm gonna do the
hash tag because we're targeting that ID
and then I'm going to say ID and then
I'm gonna specify that number all right
so now they're all unique and they will
present each other's when we click on
their individual button now if I click
on I need to clean my room you'll see
it's right there and now if I click on
this one it should say I need to clean
my floor so cool so the next step is is
that I want to edit this information and
then click Edit to transform it where to
update it so I'm gonna go down here and
I'm just gonna go over to my input and
I'm gonna run the unchanged because I
want to change the information so inside
here I'm going to say e it's going to
equal to set description I'm gonna see
II that target that value so now I could
change this thing oops I also have to
add this as well don't forget that and
now if I click Edit I can start adding
some information into this thing okay so
next what's going to happen after that
is that when I click this edit button
right here I want to be able to send
that data so this one right here is
going to be changing the description
state and this one is going to inch is
going to send that description state to
update it so I'm going to set unchanged
this unchanged and I'll click and it's
going to send a request to let's set it
to update description so this is a
function that we're going to be using
and I'm gonna put inside there alright
so we haven't set this up yet so let's
do that right now and I'm just gonna add
comments because it might be a little
bit clustered so edit description
function and what I'm going to be doing
inside there is that I'm going to make
that function so I'm just gonna do ear
function so it was called what I call
the desk I think was edit description
oh it's update description sure I'll
just do that
so update description error function and
I also want to make this peace eagerness
so I'll just add that right there a
regular try-catch error console thought
hear hear that message and I'm gonna
pass that e because I don't want this
thing to refresh yet I want to run my
code so II that prevent default okay so
that looks pretty solid so now it's time
for us to send a request so remember any
time we're gonna be adding data we have
to package this thing so I'm gonna say
constant body is going to equal to that
description okay so I'm packaging it all
up and then now I'm going to send a
response to my restful api oh if I get
spell response and I'm gonna say it wait
fetch and I have to specify that route
so HTTP slash slash local house 5000
slashed reduce and then remember we have
to also specify the ID so let's make
this template screen again and we're
just gonna say to do that to do ID right
because each one has their own unique ID
over there so once we specify this we
also have to configure it a little bit
more because like like I said again this
is automatically going to make a get
request so I have to make an object to
say that the method is actually going to
be a put request because we're updating
in the headers that's going to be a
constant type make sure you put that
string so it's gonna be a constant type
in a site here it's going to be
application slash JSON
and then I have to add that body over
there so again I'm going to package it
all up Jason dot stringify and then I'm
going to put in that body over there so
if all works well and I guess just to
double check on this let's just console
dialogue the response to make sure that
everything is working so let's do this
really quick let's go up here I'm going
to inspect so I'm gonna go to my console
and I'm gonna see if I can actually edit
this information so I'm gonna say let's
actually change this up a little bit so
I'm gonna edit this and say wash the
dishes so I'm going to edit this so it
says that it was the status of 200
that's a great sign and now what we can
do is we can check inside our command
line to see what or not that actually
did work and it says wash dishes so cool
so we're able to update our information
so the only thing that we need to do
left is just do window application slash
so we're just gonna start refreshing it
so we can see the changes being done
okay now if you look at that you can see
that changes has been done and he even
changed this back to car and you can see
the data has been updated okay cool okay
so what's next well there's also there's
something a little bit weird of this is
that if I see washing dishes and let's
say that I want to wash the clothes and
let's say I don't actually want to
change this way so if I X out of this
and I go back it doesn't change it back
to wash the dishes I don't want that I
want to be able to make sure that this
thing changes back to its original
description so let's go back into your
coding editor and let's do that so I'm
going to open this thing right here okay
so since that thing is set up there what
else okay so whenever we click on this X
button right here so where it is it this
X button we want to make sure that we
set it back to its original form so I'm
gonna set
but to this and I'm going to be running
set description I'm gonna set it back to
its original form so let me show you
that really quick so if we go inside
here and we go back to our to-do lists
and I edit this and I want to change
this to clothes and I don't want to
actually fit it and I click X it should
change it right back to it so nice so we
just need to apply this to the close
button and when we click outside so
let's go back inside here there it is
I'm gonna take this unclick right there
and I'm going to apply it to all the
other ones so remember you had a close
button so I'm gonna apply it to here and
when we click outside the mold about it
I want to make sure it resets it itself
again this wall so I'm going to be
putting that inside or is it I'm gonna
put it right there okay cool so now
let's just go back to this again so if I
decide to edit dishes now and I click up
side I'll change it back to its original
form
and if I want to edit the information
and I click Edit oops
okay sorry I actually click that so
let's say I want to clean the floor and
then I click Edit you'll see that it
adds the information I can also add data
as well add that and then finally I
could delete it so congratulations you
have officially worked on the Pern stack
so in the next section what I'm going to
do is give you guys a quick overview of
what you guys did
okay so DS remember this graph so this
is exactly what we did we created our
react application we click Submit edit
delete and is sent an HTTP request to a
restful api to instruct our database
what needs to get done now I feel like a
great way to review is just kind of
going over of how the interactive each
other so I'll just go over the side here
and I'll just show you guys what's
happening so as you can see this is our
input to do and right there we sent an
HTTP request to you - duze made a post
request and we were sending a
description as our body so if you're
looking site here that's exactly what
we're gonna be taking so let me align it
together so when you make that request
it's going to hit this route it's going
to take that description that we just
specified and then it's going to insert
that description to that value that we
specified and it's going to return it
nice now if we were to go to list adduce
so remember what we did here is that we
made a request to http localhost 5,000
/to dues so if you go down here you can
see all we did is hit that route we
selected all of the into deuce and then
we returned it back to here then we set
that as our state and then if you look
over to our edit and delete so we
actually didn't do getting to do don't
worry it's not much different so we go
to update hey to do where is it at oh
yeah there it is so whenever we were
going to update something we had to
specify exactly like what's the to do
what's going to be so I'd have to hit
slash to do is specify the IDs also say
it's a put request and then I have to
send the data that I want to replace it
with so in this case it was going to be
description right there so after that it
updated it set the description to what I
specified and I total where he was going
to be located at which was to do ID and
finally when we deleted something all we
had to do i think it's inside here yeah
so anytime we delete it all we had to do
was specify the method was delete and
hit the sprout and specify also the ID
of it so if you look down here you can
see that we put inside past this ID and
then we took that idea over there
and then we delete it from that to do
stable where that to do ID equals to
that okay so I think you're in starting
to understand of how these things are
being put together and how like full
stack applications are being built with
a burn stack so again congratulations
from here on I think a best ways to
really kind of help you build
applications is really just kind of
start building your own applications up
maybe try building leads do you list
without watching this tutorial and
really test yourself and what are not
you really mastered of just working with
the post-grad database okay but besides
then congratulations and I wish you best
of luck and building your other
applications